oh man when you see it i don't know
you know i feel like i
i you know when people talk about like
the patriarchy now and stuff like that
yeah like in the not like the [ __ ] that
jay leno said about brooklyn
yeah boobs on like live tv the way
justin timberlake just
treated her and was like totally
everyone was cool with that
that's [ __ ] up dude
i never knew jay leno said that [ __ ] i'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
my jaw hit the floor i'm like this is
crazy like i was thinking about that
line he just said and how many people
are like oh my god
how many old people like jay leno was
such a showman
such a showman like
oh it's like tattoos just getting on the
internet being like hey get a load of
these girls weird boobs
like you look at that and you'll be like
we've come a long way in terms of toxic
masculinity i think we're doing pretty
good
considering that that used to be totally
acceptable that was
totally fine it was dope yeah britney
spears is you know waxing her boobies or
whatever what did these even say
yeah okay can we get the quote hold on
it was some i like he said it and i was
like what
that's not like some weird sketch or
something
man let me what
is the can we play that justin
timberlake
uh clip real fast
a little like lean on one foot he does
and then he then he slides over and
keeps doing it
dude that bedazzled bandana like he's
dressed like a lesbian mom
at a [ __ ] like a lake party like this
[ __ ] is
i don't even say that because of his
name like that's just the vibe i get
from him
he looks like he goes to whole foods
like promotes a nudist colony or
something
yeah that little lean this is some of
the worst beatboxings
oh we play it again
[Music]
hello
who calls you lake dude yeah who calls
you late
timberlake well that's just your agent
no one else calls you that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thanks for pulling up tabitha bro how
many
how many people how many people would
try to greet him like that and justin
felt like he was a superior beat boxer
there's two morons in the room ted which
had with timberlake how we doing i'm not
as good as you
i can't quite nail it like you do but
gotta say by the way love the bandana
i could never pull that off you're
you're killing it like
dude you are killing it with that
bandana brother
how many of these [ __ ] [ __ ] made
horrible puns about his name and like
women being wet
oh man you know why they call him
timberlake
because he gets the ladies wet wetter
than an ocean out there
telling you
anyways yeah so i'm gonna take 15 of his
i'm gonna get going but uh
i [ __ ] figured it i'm [ __ ] mad
that any
any girl ever tried to tell me
that this dude was some form of an ideal
man
yeah it's crazy that you could have just
gotten away with that
i was in front of a live audience
probably like over a thousand people
bro and and i was on tv and nobody was
like
that was a little bit bad like
nothing about that was displayed any
sort of talent like
like i think there were people
i think there's definitely people like a
sound engineer saw that and was like
yo that was ass
[Laughter]
it's too scared to say anything though
he's he's probably so [ __ ] obsessed
with justin
there's his job he brings it up
okay that [ __ ] sucked right that's one
of those clips
it's jt you kidding me
that was one of those clips where i'd
allow for like a viner or someone to do
like
you know you know when they like put
themselves into that moment
but like you know people used to do that
they'd take some [ __ ] viral clip and
then
like make a vine like reacting to that
thing as if they were there
oh right okay yeah yeah that's the clip
from the studio that day
yeah yeah yeah that's the clip where i'd
let that fly like just him on stage
because like the sound engineer he just
like looks over the camera dude like
he's like yeah this [ __ ] sucks
yeah and the agents in the middle like
that's why he's the best right there wow
you're a star what a star what a star
this guy it's like you can't be stopped
[ __ ] you saw the freaking freaking
wasn't that on the hip i think it was
that i didn't think it was that good oh
cry me a river
jamie that [ __ ] was awesome
bro i'm now just like going to this
twitter thread about
justin being a [ __ ] yeah wait what
else
what else is there diane sawyer is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was like interviewing
her yeah yeah [ __ ] diane sawyer
little [ __ ] what else is there um
we pretty much like hit on all the
points for you know like the highlights
um uh
did you bring it up on screen i'll just
read this real quick
this is like uh he won man of the year
in 2006.
okay um let's go
he tells the magazine back in 2002
when the couple initially parted ways i
felt like she had a couple of
opportunities to just sort of stick up
for me and she didn't which is fine but
at that time you know i fought back
and that's the way i fought back i used
my mind i came up with a song man you're
so cool bro
you wrote a diss track for on a woman
that's crazy
that's crazy
[Laughter]
damn 2007. he gets on some awards show
and he tells brittany to stop drinking
and not to get sloppy
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] gall on this guy
man oh wait wait wait kelsey was telling
me about this other clip about
him on an award show and he makes fun of
someone's mom who's like
english isn't their first language or
something do you have that clip
uh god it was who is like shakira's mom
or something like that
and he gets he gets on stage after her
and he's like oh wasn't that cute and he
like mocks her
in her accent wow goddammit we gotta
find that
oh then uh we don't have the clip that's
fine
yo play play that yeah yeah box uh mocks
rihanna's mother's
accent oh nice justin well i wanna hear
this
i gotta hear this real quick let this
one play luke mock
award for right now and if someone
doesn't send me my real brit
in the mail
there will be hell to pay thank you very
much for this
i i'm very flattered i'm actually on
tour so i couldn't be there
everyone have a great night um stop
drinking
you know who you are i'm speaking to you
stop drinking you're gonna get sloppy
uh okay is gonna say something bad about
you
um you guys have fun tonight thank you
very much for this
whoa what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that wasn't that long ago
that wasn't 2000 man you know if
but if it wasn't for justin again her
this this is a strong-willed woman who
just
you know exactly i mean this is just
restitution for brittany's brother man
it's tough out there for dudes wow so
awesome
yeah man can keep we do have any more
clips or
is there anything else good in this holy
[ __ ]
after brittany went through her
breakdown justin oh it's a song it's a
song we can't do it
okay explain this world has
long been full of madonna wannabes and i
might have even dated a couple
but there is like this is
so right now it is one of the true
thrills and privileges of my life to
stand on this stage
and induct madonna into the rock and
roll hall of fame like when it comes to
the audience and you just see another
old dude go
yeah it's like oh my god
oh yeah bro play this 2009
i'd like to think that at first hitler
dates a popular female singer
publicly they'll claim to be virgins but
privately
he hid it
[Applause]
nice nice 2009
2009 why are we still talking about her
virginity
nice snl and how she lost it is [ __ ]
weird
yeah it's just like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
oh man this is this is crazy it's pretty
alarming when you see all this [ __ ]
back to back right yeah you just you
just kind of highlight like
i mean when you're a punching bag for
like
20 years it has to make you go a little
bit
and i mean i'm not calling i mean she i
don't know i'm not calling her crazy
she's definitely a little off right you
look at her instagram post and you're
like something's not right here
but i think i think i'd be off if i was
in her scenario as well i think so too
that's what i'm saying like nice
it's just it's man we've laughed at her
posts on this
podcast yeah no we're completely getting
arrested before
yeah but it's just i don't know it's
wild when you see it like this is like
oh my god she's
i didn't know idea you know i was just
part of this
i think that's the problem though i
think that
you know from that tabloid era like they
just
spun one message and that [ __ ] stuck
with you like you just kind of thought
oh yeah that's that's got to be it's got
to be true right
you know she shaved her head like she's
[ __ ] nuts right yeah
and uh i mean it just it just sucks
like it and it's so
it when you think about it it's [ __ ]
pathetic like how many [ __ ]
supposed comedy writers and show writers
and
all of this [ __ ] just were like oh what
if we did a britney joke
yeah damn this whole game
you guys have been a hack for like how
long now
that [ __ ] is wild man oh my god yeah
dude let's do like a throwback joke
about you
you [ __ ] britney spears when you guys
were dating in the 90s
remember that when she claimed she was a
virgin should we throw it back to that
that'd be cool oh bogus claimed that she
was a virgin when we all know you
[ __ ] hit it dog
right lake right you're freaking lazy
freaking freaking hit it dog
you got in that pika pika [ __ ] dog
you were in brittany's [ __ ] puss
right brittany sucked you off dog you
ear i don't know
you just been drinking women respect or
juice for like the last 30 minutes but
it was you know it was [ __ ] up all
that was [ __ ] up
you